hi there Steve Kaufman here to talk
about compelling input or comprehensible
input these are two terms that come up
all the time in language learning
remember if you like these videos about
language learning please subscribe and
if you like a particular video don't
hesitate to give it a like it does help
me in my rankings on YouTube um okay so
compelling input comprehensible input
see I these are some of the sort of key
buzzwords in language learning and
they're very important because as I've
said many times you know interesting
content compelling content where you are
sort of interested in the subject matter
that drives our learning and if it were
possible to have sort of just an ideal
gradual progression from sort of
extremely easy material yet interesting
gradually moving towards content that's
longer and a little more difficult and
yet interesting you know suits our
interests at our level I mean that's the
ideal world however that is not a
realistic expectation it doesn't happen
in real life and there are a variety of
reasons for this one is that at the very
beginning of course nothing is
comprehensible so you you can't start
with material that's comprehensible you
start with material that may become
comprehensible in other words if it's
short if it uses a lot of very
high-frequency words if you have access
to online dictionaries if you have
access to a translation or if you
familiar with the story then all of
these things help to make it at least if
not immediately comprehensible something
that can become comprehensible with
enough exposure to it so then you start
from something that's not comprehensible
and you gradually move towards material
that is comprehensible and at the same
time hopefully more interesting because
very often the beginner material isn't
very calm
Hansol know in my own experience here
with Turkish of course the
comprehensible however not very
compelling material or input that I used
initially was are many stories at link I
have now used them in Greek in Arabic in
Persian I've dabbled with them in other
languages I know the stories so they are
not compelling however I am interested
in learning Turkish a new language
therefore I prefer for a long time to
listen to materialist not compelling but
is potentially comprehensible because
there's so much repetition within each
story words repeat and repeat and repeat
I start to get a sense of the language
so this material is not intrinsically
compelling but it is at least accessible
in terms of comprehension so at the
other end of the spectrum I now find
that in my Turkish I want to get to more
material that is intrinsically
compelling and so I have been because
again my interest in Turkish started
with my wife watching Turkish dramas on
Netflix and so now I discovered that on
Netflix website if I use an app that one
of my listeners here recommended called
learning languages on Netflix or
something like that then then I can see
the subtitles in Turkish and in English
and so I try to follow along and I can
control the speed of these subtitles and
the translation using the arrow keys on
my keypad however it's still extremely
difficult because the translation isn't
perfect and I feel that I would like to
understand better what those words mean
and so forth so there is another app
that someone recommended called
sub Adama and that gives me the
possibility to download the SRT file of
all of the transcript
all of these subtitles as a transcript
and then the next thing I
found was a website that will convert
the srt file to a text file so I'm able
to import all the transcripts into link
we haven't yet figured a way out a way
to get the sound into link as a lesson
but at least I have the text so now I am
going through this movie go new which I
watched for 10-15 minutes on my computer
following with the subtitles then I go
and study it on link get at some of the
words and phrases then I go back to
watching the movie then I go back to
working at link and it really is
wonderful so this is compelling input
but it's not immediately comprehensible
and even when I go through it on my in
link this is conversation flying back
and forth and of course even if I know
the words the word order in Turkish is
to my mind I'm not used to it yet and so
therefore even looking at Beech word I
still can't make sense of the whole
phrase I find that Google Translate for
Turkish does a very good job of doing
that so I'm getting a feel for Turkish
word order at least in these casual
conversations but the point is that with
more or less one month into Turkish I am
watching movies which is compelling
input I'm studying the text of those
movies on link this is all compelling
input the difficulty with going in a
very gradual way from comprehensible
input to compelling input at what some
of these language teaching experts refer
to as n plus one sort of that next level
of difficulty it's simply not possible
because of what I explained in an
earlier video and that is that that word
frequency drops off very very rapidly so
the idea that you could always have just
that next level of you know percentage
of new words is kind of unrealistic in
fact you will always be dealing with a
lot of new words and to me vocabulary is
the key in terms of comprehension
yeah word order I mean I'll get used to
the word order and and even to see an
explanation of word order doesn't do it
you actually have to see and experience
to live how you know Turks
express themselves and and how they
throw the words together there make a
sentence just to say subject verb object
or subject object verb doesn't do it
that all of these are theoretical
explanations are not as effective as
exposing your mind to the actual
language and allowing your brain to get
used to it
so I guess my point is that the main
thing again is to engage with the
language just to do something it's like
when you go to a gym it doesn't matter
if you're gonna go on the stepper you're
gonna go on the treadmill are you gonna
use this machine or that machine just go
there and do something just commit
yourself to doing something now that
something is gonna vary and I find
myself alternating between
comprehensible input witches are mini
stories and then more compelling input
which is a bit more of a struggle but
extremely enjoy enjoyable and as I'm
doing it I'm confident that just
allowing this language to flow over my
brain even though I can't say anything
in Turkish it's gradually getting my
brain used to the language and at some
point I will start to speak and I've
only been in Turkish for one month I'm
actually enjoying a Turkish movie I
don't remember having been able to do
that in any other language now part of
that is simply the availability of all
the different resources and online
dictionaries and and systems like link
and so forth which make it possible to
do things now that I couldn't do before
so I just wanted to talk a bit about
this sort of comprehensible versus
compelling input at an initial stage
simple content with a lot of repetition
because I'm I'm so motivated to try to
get a handle on the language is in a way
compelling even though it's not
genuinely authentically interesting but
at a later stage we can actually find
ways of engaging with content that is
inherently
interesting compelling like these movies
and yet really it's not at that n plus-1
level of difficulty it's not genuinely
on its own comprehensible but we can
make it comprehensible and in both
situations we are allowing the language
to flow over our brain and the brain is
gradually going to sort things out
so a bit of a rant there on
comprehensible and compelling input
you